beaucoup merci bonne
[Musique]
journée et notre invité ce matin c'est
François Xavier ménage bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous vous êtes
grand reporter et auteur de ce livre ça
craque plongé dans une France
silencieuse mais explosive on va en
parler c'est chez Robert Lafond ce livre
c'est le fruit de 5 ans de reportage de
votre part c'est un tour de France
finalement de ces français qu'on nentend
jamais dans les petites villes dans les
bandlieux dans le monde rural vous êtes
allé à la rencontre de tous les
territoires et vous en avez fait un état
de la France d'aujourd'hui elle va mal
la France de 2023 elle va pas très bien
je crois que c'est pas du breaking news
que de le dire pour autant le constat
mon métier c'est pas de dire que la
France va s'écrouler dans 10 ans
personne d'ailleurs dans dans dans ce
livre ne le dit en revanche et c'est ce
qui est frappant et et je crois que
c'est constaté par beaucoup c'est
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez beaucoup de
Français qui lutte l'inflation est un
des ingrédients malheureusement de cette
lutte et puis vous avez aussi une une
multitude de casquettes qui sont portées
par beaucoup d'acteurs de de la France
que ce soit parce qu'il faut pas de
populisme dans le constat évidemment tel
qu'on le donne que ce soit en haut ou en
bas de la pyramide et et moi c'est
c'estes multiples luttes qui à mon avis
dit quelque chose de la France éant
entendu par ailleurs que et je pense que
c'est aussi quelque chose qui est
frappant on a de plus en plus de mal à
comprendre ce que vit notre voisin ce
que vit par exemple la commune à côté
voire même évidemment ce qui se passe à
l'autre bout de la France et parce que
on est dans un pays qui est fragmenté
tous les politologues le disent je pense
qu'il faut aller sur le terrain raconter
cette fragmentation essayer de
comprendre comment chacun lutte comment
chacun avance parce que la France elle
avance très vite et qu'on est parfois un
peu paumé on va y revenir évidemment
dans le détail puisque vous abordez
plusieurs sujets on a beaucoup parlé de
cette France périphérique au moment des
gilets jaunes est-ce que cette France
périphérique c'est toujours l'opposition
à la France des métropoles est-ce
qu'elle est juste cette analyse ou
est-ce qu' aujourd'hui c'est plus
compliqué que ça j'aurais envie de vous
dire que c'est plus compliqué que ça
mais je prends soin de préciser que pour
TF1 moi j'avais ouvert les les gilets
jaunes et les premières manifestations
les les samedis enfin je l'ai fait
pendant 3 mois et j'étais frappé de voir
d'abord que des Français s'exprimaient
pour la première fois sur leurs
difficultés n'avaient pas peur de dire
qu'il vivaient avec 500 600 700 € par
mois et surtout s'étonnent de s'exprimer
s'étonnait devant la caméra de dire ce
que je suis en train de dire je pensais
jamais que j'allais le dire publiquement
et et cette parole là si on prend un
petit peu de distance déjà était un
élément quand même constitutif de de
cette France silencieuse qui concerne
énormément de personnes et par ailleurs
ement sur sur le constat tel qu'on le
qu'on l'expliquait il y a la France
périphérique mais d'une certaine manière
moi c'est ce qui me frappe aussi la
périphérie peut être à l'intérieur d'une
ville je prends plusieurs exemples
notamment aras où il y a beaucoup
d'habitants qui disent attendez il y a
les trottoirs des riches les trottoirs
des pauvres les trottoirs qui sont
privilégiés où les commerces peuvent
s'installer et être aidés justement dans
leurs installations et puis vous avez
quelques rues plus loin ce sentiment de
décrocher c'est-à-dire que en terme de
territorialité j'ai ce sentiment que la
périphérie peut être partout et là aussi
c'est un constat qu'on ne faisait
peut-être pas il y a 10 ans et qui moi
en tout cas en tant que journaliste he
je ne suis que journaliste m'interpelle
lors de sa campagne présidentielle il y
a 6 ans Emmanuel Macron il avait promis
de parler à cette France périphérique de
recoudre le lien entre cette France
périphérique et cette France des
métropoles les Français que vous avez
rencontré sur le terrain 6 ans après
est-ce qu'ils se sonent toujours oubliés
alors par rapport au au au dialogue avec
la politique là encore sans généraliser
et et sans faire de populisme moi ce qui
me marque c'est que j'ai rencontré des
centaines de personnes dans ce livre et
et et j'ai ce privilège de vraiment
avoir pu parler à à toutes sortes de
personnes qui bien souvent avancent dans
leur coin sans faire de bruit et à
chaque fois qu'on parle de politique
c'est parce que moi j'ai posé la
question moi c'est une matière qui
m'intéresse à tout point de vue mais ça
ne vient jamais de mes interlocuteurs
que ce soit une directrice d'école que
ce soit un ouvrier que ce soit quelqu'un
qui travaille dans l'agroalimentaire
voit même un avocat la question
politique telle qu'on la conçoit je
trouve y compris dans les médias n'est
pas toujours perçu de la même manière je
donne juste un exemple quand c'est vrai
on dit par exemple parce qu'il y a une
crise je laisse le covid de côté à cause
du du confinement bien sûr mais quand on
dit attention on va voir quel sera la
parole du gouvernement du premier
ministre ou du président à 20h quand il
va s'exprimer oui ça nous interpelle
nous journalistes mais moi sur le
terrain je vois personne à me dire ah
j'attends de savoir ce que dira le
président pour ensuite me faire ma
propre opinion comme si parce que pour
eux c'est plus la solution le politique
je ne sais pas mais en tout cas c'est
dans la pièce d'à côté ça n'est plus
dans le champ de vision de beaucoup de
Français là encore généralisons pas mais
mais pour beaucoup c'est effectivement
dans la pièce d'à côté et quand ça
s'extirpe de ce champ de vision et de ce
champ lexical je pense qu'évidemment
c'est c'est c'est pas forcément une
bonne nouvelle alors comment retisser
moi c'est pas mon métier de donner les
réponses mais déjà commençons par ça
mais ils ont probablement besoin de ça
on a tous besoin de ça évidemment de
retisser oui vous avez divisé votre
livre en plusieurs thématiques hein
évidemment alors il y en a des
nombreuses on va pas pouvoir parler
toutes même même si elles sont toutes
passionnantes on en a sélectionné
certaines a commencé par la santé le
système de santé céit un un peu la
fierté de la France en tout cas la la
France se targaet d'avoir le meilleur
système de santé au monde et puis il y a
eu le covid et là on a vu que ce n'était
pas le cas on a vu les difficultés des
soignants des médecins dans les hôpitaux
est-ce que la France aujourd'hui est
devenue un immense désert médical oui
alors il y a des chiffres qui circulent
qui évoquent 800 % de déseres médical il
y a quand même 6 millions de Français
qui n'ont pas de médecins généralistes
et en 2023 moi c'est peut-être ce qui
m'a le plus frappé c'est que on va vers
une rupture qui n'est pas globale bien
entendu mais aujourd'hui on va être très
concret et et c'est là où j'ai fait le
le reportage pour parler des médecins
qui se déréférencent on connaît le
secteur 1 le secteur 2 et aujourd'hui
vous avez plusieurs centaines de
médecins qui sont secteur 3 ça veut dire
hors remboursement de la Sécurité
sociale ça veut donc dire que quand vous
allez voir ces médecins vous n'êtes pas
remboursé alors que vous cotisez bien
entendu pour la sécurité sociale et à
nior il y a notamment un médecin qui a
dit moi j'ai arrêté d'être référencé
parce que parce que burnout parce que
j'en pouvais plus de faire de l'abattage
de patients ce sont ces mots et donc le
plus intéressant c'est de voir ensuite
quels sont les patients qui viennent le
voir et ceux qui viennent le voir sont
en grande majorité issu des classes
moyennes ont des difficultés pour
boucler leur fin de mois mais se disent
tout de même que parce qu'ils n'ont pas
pu avoir de médecins généraliste parce
que ils n'ont pas eu de médecin tout
simplement parce qu'il y a pas de
rendez-vous et bien ils prennent le
risque d'aller voir un médecin
dééréférencé qui effectivement leur
donnera un rendez-vous dans les 48 heur
mais je parle de risque parce que c'est
leur pouvoir d'achat qui est entamé et
quand ils répondent à ma question je
leur dis pourquoi vous faites ça
pourquoi vous allez perdre 50 € alors
que vous pourriez effectivement les
gagnés ailleurs ils me répondent c'est
comme ça c'est comme ça c'est mon choix
et je trouve que c'est quand même un un
constat qu'il faut mettre en avant étant
entendu par ailleurs que vous avez 1500
à 2000 médecins qui sont pour l'instant
conventionnés qui sont sur le point
d'appuyer sur le bouton et de dire on se
déconventionne voilà la santé en France
en 2023 c'est une partie de cette dé
avec un risque de médecine à deux
vitesses forcment avec un risque mais
qui a donc démarré qui pour l'instant
est un filme il faut là aussi garder un
peu de distance mais en tout cas qui
commence à à prendre de l'ampleur et
puis vous racontez aussi ceux qui font
tenir le système hein vous parlez
notamment de cette infirmière libérale à
Oudan à Poline qui travaille 7 jours sur
7 euh elle ne fait pas que les
pansements les piqûes elle fait aussi
les courses c'est c'est grâce à des gens
comme ça que notre système de santé
tient encore aujourd'hui en tout cas
elle l'estime elle que elle est dans une
sorte de mission elle le fait sans
jamais tirer la couette à elle moi je
l'ai rencontré par le plus grand des
hasards elle avait pas levé la main pour
dire j'ai envie qu'on parle de moi et ça
c'est très important je pense en terme
de représentation et et Apoline
effectivement a travaillé 360 5 jours
nonstop sans un samedi sans un dimanche
où elle pouvait s'arrêter elle a trois
enfants à la maison et donc sa vie est
basée effectivement sur l'aide aux
patients parfois elle peut passer 1
heure dans les maisons de personnes qui
pour le reste du temps ne discutent avec
personne elle ne fait pas toute la
paperacee qui est nécessaire pour être
remboursé mais elle dit voilà j'y vais
j'avance ils ont besoin de moi et ce
qu'elle dit aussi qui je pense est
symptomatique de de l'état actuel
malheureusement du système de santé même
si certaines choses s'améliorent c'est
qu'elle dit à ses patients si vraiment
c'est grave et qu'il faut aller aux
urgences mentez exagéré dites que vous
avez vraiment très très mal parce que
sinon vous ne serez pas pris en charge
et donc se dessine une certaine France
de la débrouillardise contrainte et et
souvent malheureuse mais cette
desbrouillardise là aussi elle raconte
quelque chose de de la France plastique
de 2023 je crois vous parlez aussi
beaucoup des élus dans votre livre on va
venir mais notamment sur cette question
de la santé vous racontez l'histoire de
ce maire qui pour décrocher un médecin
fait appel à un détective privé
racontez-nous des années des années de
de bataille on est en Centre-Bretagne
pour espérer avoir un un médecin de
campagne et alors là c'est une vérité
qui va parler à beaucoup d'élus mais ça
ne marche pas et donc parce qu'il y a un
détective dans le coin qui travaille
pour en règle général résoudre plutôt
des des histoires d'adultère ou alors
des des des espionnages dans les petites
entreprises et ben il appelle ce
détective et il dit est-ce que vous
pourriez nous trouver un médecin de
campagne et c'est la suite qui est la
plus intéressante c'est-à-dire que il y
a ensuite une décision qui est prise en
conseil municipal il y a une ligne
budgétaire qui est voté par les élus de
la République et donc 2000 € sont
alloués à ce détective pour qu'il trouve
un médecin de campagne et c'est la suite
encore qui est la plus intéressante il
trouve un médecin c'est un parfait et ce
médecin de campagne va partir et c'est
un autre qui va venir après mais il y a
d'autres communes ensuite qui appelle ce
détective et qui disent ah oui mais nous
on a besoin aussi d'une infirmière et on
a besoin d'un oftalmo et on a besoin
d'un kiné et donc là encore d'une
certaine manière une France de la
débrouillardise qui travaille dans son
coin avec des problèmes locaux des
réponses locales et ça dit non pas un
divorce avec les élites bien sûr mais
mais ça raconte aussi quelque chose qui
est un petit peu du du détachement d'une
certaine façon cette France est aussi
évidemment la France qui a des
difficultés de pouvoir d'achat la France
de la précarité notamment précarité
énergétique notamment Zili qui habite à
ames qui se prive de chauffage est-ce
que ces derniers mois avec la guerre en
Ukraine vous avez constaté encore une
aggravation de cette précarité
énergétique dans le pays alors elle
s'est aggravé bien entendu cette cette
précarité énergétique lors de l'hiver
dernier tout le monde de la vie générale
est d'accord pour dire que ça va
probablement encore s'accentuer mais ce
qui était intéressant avec ce cas qui là
encore est symptomatique c'est que cette
femme qui est donc donc une mère de
famille qui se bat effectivement pour
pour les fins de mois dès le 10 du mois
cette femme sollicite des aides qu'elle
n'obtient pas et ensuite tente par tous
les moyens de trouver des des solutions
courttermistes parce qu'elle a du mal à
se projeter à horizon 2 3 4 5 ans et
derrière cela il y a effectivement un
décrochage qui se généralise parce que
je suis allé voir ensuite le Secours
Catholique de de meurthosel qui nous dit
qu'eectivement il y a une accélération
très importante de de ceux qui
décrochent qui sont obligés de choisir
on le sait entre le logement et la
nourriture et donc et bien les
associations disent on est en train de
faire le travail de trait d'union que
l'État a du mal à faire sur le terrain
et ce qui est intéressant aussi parce
qu'il y a beaucoup d'espoirs dans ce
livre tout de même c'est que les
associations ce qui se faisaient jamais
avant en mort etmosel se sont toutes
mises autour de la table pour dire
comment on fait pour aider ceux qui n'y
arrivent pas dans leur démarche mais
comment on fait pour le faire ensemble
donc il y a une structuration des
associations qui se met en place
localement c'est vrai en meuriselle
c'est vrai ailleurs aussi et là aussi
qui répond localement à des problèmes
locaux oui vous fait bien de le dire
parce que c'est aussi une France
solidaire qu'on découvre dans ce livre
mais ceux qui sont censés venir en aide
aux plus pauvres les associations les
assistante sociale elle-même se retrouve
en difficulté cque et craque aussi et là
peut-être je pense qu'un exemple alors
qu'on parle de la bagnole en ce moment
depuis depuis dimanche dernier moi
j'aime la bagnole dit le président de la
République c'est vrai que beaucoup lui
répondront moi la bagnole j'en ai besoin
je ne peux pas faire autrement et là
aussi dans la France de 2023 me
semble-t-il un élément très important
c'est qu'aujourd'hui les bénévoles
d'association par exemple famille rurale
en nor dans des petites villes où ces
bénévoles viennentaider ceux qui ne
peuvent pas se déplacer parce qu'il y a
pas de transport public parce que la
voiture coûte trop cher et bien ces
bénévoles font des déplacements
notamment pour les personnes âgées pour
aller voir par exemple des des médecins
ou aller à l'hôpital et bien les
bénévoles disent eux-même c'est plus
possible il faut nous aider nous à
mettre de l'essence dans la voiture pour
continuer à aider donc quand on voit que
le tissu associatif local et ce sont des
associations qui ne font pas de bruit là
encore quand ces associations disent on
a vraiment besoin de l'aide de l'État
pour continuer pour faire le boulot que
l'État pourrait peut-être faire on voit
qu'on est dans un cercle vicieux et que
là aussi ça doit interroger bien sûr
parce que c'est ça vous dites il y a
ceux qui répondront au président de la
République moi j'ai besoin de ma bagnole
mais il y a aussi ceux qui disent ben
moi j'aimerais bien me servir de ma
bagnole sauf que je peux pas et vous
parlez notamment de Nathalie adreux elle
a une expression elle parle de
confinement carburant confinement
carburant alors là aussi rencontré par
le les trésors si je puis dire de du du
terrain je la rencontre par hasard est
en train de discuter avec une de ses
voisines et ce qu'elle dit là encore je
pense raconte tristement quelque chose
elle dit moi ma mère est malade dans le
nord de la France c'est de 200 à 300 km
pour aller la voir je n'ai pas pu depuis
3 mois parce que j'ai dû faire des choix
et cette même personne nous dit il y
aura pas de vacances sa copine à côté
dit moi non plus il y a pas de vacances
mes enfants non plus donc tout est
effectivement compté et quand on en
vient effectivement à compter ses
déplacements qu'une colère s'installe
qui est parfois nourrie parfois qui ne
l'est pas là aussi effectivement je
pense qu'il faut raconter ce quotidien
là partir du terrain pour ensuite
comprendre un petit peu mieux où
nous-même on habite cé en tout cas
l'idée de ce livre savoir où habitent
les les les voisins les français pour
ensuite réussir à se définir aussi et
vous racontez aussi la galère dans les
TER notamment vous prenez l'exemple
d'Hakim qui à cause des retards des
annulations de train doit dépenser des
sommes en en nuit d'hôtel c'est aussi ça
la galère des Français aujourd'hui et
son quotidien à Hakim c'est d'avoir un
sac de sport dans lequel et bien il y a
toujours des affaires au cas où il ne
rentre pas chez lui le soir il a 150 km
à faire en train du nord de la France
jusqu'à la banlieue parisienne et donc
tous les matins depuis sa maison il part
avec un sac de sport parce qu'il ne sait
pas s'il pourra rentrer parce qu'il y a
des trains qui sont annulés en pagaille
et que c'est un réseau qui est
malheureusement é véuste et qui manque
d'investissement et où les les pannes
sont fréquentes et donc là aussi ce
quotidien là où on dit je continue
j'avance mais tout ça est difficile
évidemment il faut pouvoir le souligner
et par ailleurs il y a auensite les
mécanismes politiques locaux qui se
mettent en place qui s'occupe de ce
réseau on voit la bataille entre le
Conseil régional et la SNCF c'est
ensuite ce contexte-là journalistique
que je que je donne à chaque fois dans
les chapitres pour là aussi comprendre
les mécanismes qui sont plus
macroéconomiques mais on part du terrain
pour ensuite comprendre quelles
décisions sont prises est-ce qu'elles
sont bonnes est-ce qu'elles ne sont pas
bonnes c'est pas à moi d'en juger mais
ensuite on essaie de comprendre un petit
peu plus à chaque fois en partant de
d'exemples précis et on a l'impression
que malgré les difficultés il y a une
forme de résignation euh vous parlez
souvent des gens qui vous disent ben on
a pas le choix elle est résignée cette
France là alors moi c'est vrai que c'est
quelque chose qui me marque aussi c'est
que souvent c'est une colère qui est
renfermé voir éteinte il y a pas tant de
colère que ça chez tous ceux que j'ai pu
rencontrer sur le terrain qui sont tous
dans l'action he personne ne reste chez
lui devant sa télé à dire c'est foutu on
va tous crever et la France c'est
terminée c'est pas du tout ça ils sont
tous dans l'action dans plusieurs
actions c'est ce que je disais tout à
l'heure avec les multicasquettes mais
leur colère est souvent éteinte
j'entends pas parler de révolution
j'entends pas parler de faut renverser
la table j'entends parler de comment je
fais demain et et là aussi ce champ de
vision qui n'est peut-être pas toujours
celui qu'on perçoit nous quand quand on
évoque les choses autour de la table
dans les plateaux télé je pense que
c'est important aussi de de le mesurer
parce que on n'est pas tant dans la
colère que dans l'acceptation même si
c'est très dur avec toujours quand même
cette idée de se dire comment je vais
trouver des solutions au niveau local et
comment moi qui souffre j'essaie aussi
par la débrouillardise bien souvent de
de trouver des solutions vous nous
racontez aussi les la transformation de
nos ville et notamment de nos
centre-ville alors il y a évidemment la
question des petits commerces qui
ferment et de cette désertification dans
les centres-villees et puis il y a la
question de la drogue du trafic de
drogue qui s'installe maintenant dans de
nombreuses villes de France est-ce que
les Français que vous avez rencontré ils
se sent en sécurité aujourd'hui alors
sur les deux exemples que vous avez
donné c'est très intéressant et je vous
remercie parce que ça permet là encore
de je pense évoquer une France qui
évolue sur les petits commerces d'un mot
on a des solutions vous avez des
managers de ville aujourd'hui
c'est-à-dire que vous avez des communes
qui voient que les commerces ferment en
pagaill saint-briux 20 % de commerce
fermé voire parfois plus et et par
exemple cette ville dit OK et ben on va
on va embaucher chez des personnes dont
le métier est justement d'essayer de
rgénérer en quelque sorte la marque
ville comme on pourrait le faire dans le
marketing chez L'Oréal ou d'on et
concernant le la drogue et bien là aussi
le rapport est en train de s'inverser il
y a de nouveaux concepts de nouveaux
mots qui arrivent à Avignon qui est donc
gangrené par le trafic de drogue avec
des points deal où on peut jusqu'à 30000
€ on peut gagner jusqu'à 30000 € quand
on est dealer par jour sur ces boins de
Deal et bien en face vous avez la police
qui dit on va faire du harcèlement moi
dans mon inconscient à moi je pensais
que harcèlement c'était du côté des
dealers et bien les policiers vous
disent non on on a du mal à à démanteler
ces trafics qui sont très modulables et
donc ce qu'on fait c'est que tous les
soirs et il faut raconter ce quotidien
vous avez des policiers qui font des
patrouilles qui bien souvent n'arrivent
pas à intercepter les dealers mais qui
en faisant ses patrouilles c'est ce que
eux disent je les cite et bien ça leur
permet de ne pas perdre de mètres carrés
de territoire et donc ils disent notre
stratégie c'est le harcèlement donc on
voit également des mots surgir comme ça
des actions qui là encore raconte un
petit peu la France de 2023 sur le plan
insécuritaire notamment c'est assez
étonnant est-ce que vous avez constaté
un sentiment d'inquiétude chez les
Français et tout à l'heure vous nous
disiez les Français ils voient pas
forcément ce qui se passe chez le voisin
ils en tiennent pas forcément compte
est-ce que de ce sentiment d'inquiétude
peut nître la tentation du repli sur soi
alors c'est là encore une très bonne
question souvent je précise je je je
considère et je m'inclus dedans que
comme cette France est effectivement
éclatée et politiquement et socialement
et économiquement on a de plus en plus
de mal peut-être pas à s'intéresser mais
à comprendre ce qui se passe parfois
juste à côté de chez nous et c'est la
raison de ce livre mais euh ce qui est
vrai aussi c'est que il y a surtout de
l'incompréhension et et je compare ça
effectivement à à un tableau d'art
moderne on pourrait dire un tableau de
Nicolas de Stal où on voit tous une
perception différente selon l'endroit où
on est à 1 m à 10 m à gauche à droite et
et et je pense que puisqu'on parle de
narration puisqu'on parle de du grand
récit de la France euh aujourd'hui ce
qui est certain c'est qu'on ne voit pas
le même tableau et et c'est pour ça je
justement que je le fais expliquer à
beaucoup de Français parce que c'est ce
qu'il me disent c'est ce qu'il me disent
vous parlez aussi du rôle des élus hein
c'est vrai que c'est un peu une AE aux
élus quand même votre livrein qui aide
évidemment ces Français qui sont un peu
le le pilier de la France un élu c'est
quelqu'un qui se bat au quotidien est-ce
que c'est pas un peu dommageable
aujourd'hui qu'un élu doiv se battre
mais c'est dommageable pour eux parce
que dans le morbillan qui est pas le
département le plus en crise de France
vous avez l'association des mes de
France départementale donc qui a décidé
il y a peu de temps de calculer le taux
de démission des élus depuis les
dernières élections municipales et ce
taux de démission moi c'est probablement
peut-être un des chiffres qui m'a le
plus marqué ce taux de démission il est
de 15 % ça veut donc dire aujourd'hui
que dans un département j'insiste qui
est pas celui qui est le plus en crise
et bien les élus démissionnent cinq fois
plus que dans le secteur privé alors
qu'on parle de la grande démission et
que pour plein de raisons différentes
que j'explique dans le livre ces élus
n'y arrive plus et disent je lâche bien
là aussi il faut essayer de comprendre
ce ce contexte là mais est-ce que si ces
élus finissent par lâcher il commence à
le faire vous l'avez très bien dit et
vous le racontez la France va craquer
encore plus alors je suis pas astrologue
je n'en suis pas sûr parce que une fois
de plus l'un des piliers c'est quand
même aussi la débrouillardise à tous les
étages et je prends soin de préciser que
ça doit pas être simple d'être homme ou
femme politique peu importe l'étage
aujourd'hui en France mais mais mais ce
qui est certain c'est que en tout cas ça
interroge un modèle ça va très vite
notre pays il a avance beaucoup plus
vite qu'on le comprend tous je pense
c'est difficile de saisir ce qui se
passe et cette accélération comme un TGV
qu'on a du mal à on narrive pas à
compter les les wagons ben je pense que
c'est un petit peu la même chose et donc
ben ce qui se passera après j'en sais
rien du tout mais en tout cas je suis
sûr qu'il ne se passe jamais ce qu'on
croit ce qui va se passer vous vous vous
avez couvert de nombreux conflits hein
évidemment est-ce que vous terminez ce
livre en parlant de la question des
émeutes notamment de de ce qui s'est
passé à à greini enfin vous parlez de
greini et du coup ça nous renvoie
évidemment à la question des émeutes
vous parlez de ce volcan et vous nous
l'avez dit le mot qui qui qui revient en
tout cas qu'on retient dans ce livre
c'est la question de débrouillardise
est-ce que cette France justement elle
tient grâce à la débrouillardise et
est-ce que cette débrouillardise elle va
empêcher ce volcan dont vous parlez
d'exploser à grininy c'est ce qui s'est
passé soyons très concrets Grini est à
une vingtaine de kilomètres de Paris
Grini ville tristement la plus pauvre de
France 30000 habitants greini n'a pas de
supermarché parce qu'autour vous avez
d'autres supermarché dans les villes
alentour qui disent non on veut pas que
celui-ci s'installe sinon ça va faire
baisser notre notre chiffre d'affaires
et donc il y a une bataille judiciaire
qui dure depuis des années et des années
et bien la débrouillardise consiste
effectivement d'abord pour les habitants
à faire parfois des kilomètres pour
aller trouver des produits pas chers
dans les rayons des super marché à côté
et il a des brouillardis aussi ce sont
pour les élus locaux ce sont pour les
parents d'élèves aussi notamment de
faire un travail quand il y a les émeut
qui consiste à dire attention attention
attention si on casse l'école là on va
tous être dans la merde pardonnez-moi
l'expression c'est ce que j'ai j'ai
beaucoup entendu et donc vous avez des
parents qui ont campé pendant des nuits
dans les écoles rejoints par les élus
locaux et effectivement greini n'a pas
basculé alors que lors des précédentes
émeutes ça avait été un des centres
névralgiques de de la crise des banlieux
et donc on le voit il y a au niveau
local mais partout d'ailleurs il y a des
choses qui se mettent en place
maintenant quelle réponse de l'État
comment coordonner tout ça comment mieux
comprendre aussi ce qui se passe autour
de nous bon on termine par une autre
d'espoir quand même François Dav ménage
ça craque mais ça tient ça tient ça
tient ça tient et et il y a vraiment il
y a des des des dizaines et des dizaines
de héros dans ce livre dont on peut
saluer le boulot parce que ils avancent
ils avancent et ils font tenir la France
et effectivement vous êtes allé à la
rencontre sans populisme j'insiste que
c'est vraiment pas le principe c'est du
terrain c'est le terrain qui décide et
vous êtes allé à la rencontre de cette
France silencieuse dont on a envie
d'entendre parler votre livre est
passionnant et riche en en témoignage et
très humain merci beaucoup merci
François Xavier ménage d'avoir été votre
invité on le revoit votre livre he ça
craque un reporter de guerre dans une
France explosive c'est aux éditions
Robert Lafond merci d'avoir été notre
invité on passe au club de territo